welcome back to the iced coffee hour i'm
brandon with investmentjoy and so far
the iced coffee hours made a hundred and
sixty four thousand one hundred twenty
three dollars that's the closest guess
we've had so far that is actually true
oh good it's one hundred and twenty four
thousand a hundred and twenty four
thousand yeah and if you guys are
wondering why this is the exact same as
last episode that is because we are
doing back-to-back episodes i've never
done before in this you know this quick
a time so welcome
okay cool so i can feel uncomfortable
because i was like oh my gosh i'm coming
on the heels of someone much much more
affluent famous than i am do you not
realize
everybody else you don't realize how uh
internet famous you become
you are like the tick tock sensation you
just did a million subscribers on
youtube your videos are going more viral
than any of ours ever have by a
magnitude of like 10.
yeah but it's all from youtube shorts
and those like really don't count but
this doesn't matter here's the thing i
bet a lot of people might be watching to
be like oh who's investment joy where
have i seen him before
well
almost guaranteed if you've opened tick
tock almost a hundred percent you've
seen how much your laundromats make or
how much the uh the what
the one i really enjoyed from you was
the game where you put in a coin oh yeah
the quarter pusher the quarter pusher
i
loved that uh you on a multitude of busy
you're looking at a car wash you own
real estate
you're basically the go-to of viral
content uh but but it's business related
it has to do with making money yeah i
mean wow you really talked me up i need
to hire you guys
for my stuff
no it's incredible because i
i remember and you are actually one of
the first people to go like mega viral
on youtube uh in the finance space and
it was your video how much do you make
with the laundromat and i remember that
video just
i think it was like four million views
in a few days in the first few years
yeah at peak if memory surgery was
october the 19th 2019 very shortly after
i was on a certain other podcast we have
to provide some proper background to
this because on the second channel when
we first started it we used to do these
things where we'd get people to call in
and then graham would basically provide
financial advice not financial advice
right okay not financial advice
entertainment right to talk about
finances maybe what the caller could be
doing better and it also didn't
necessarily have to be about finances
but just generally taking calls kind of
like dave ramsey right and uh you came
on the i i organized your call to come
on and i think you had at the time like
500 subscribers was it uh i was a little
over two thousand oh was it over two
thousand it was over 2000 subscribers
but they weren't doing anything i
sourced all my subscribers essentially
from posting on reddit all the time got
it okay yeah but it just it wasn't
enough watch time that was a problem i
had subscribers but not watch time so
you came on and you talked about owning
what was like 60 or it was like 100
rentals it was almost at that point i
think that was right before i bought the
trailer park so i was at like 90 rentals
and then right title said what's like
owning almost 100 rentals yeah and you
were considering buying a trailer park
and i thought it'd be an interesting
call so i scheduled you in to talk with
graham you came on and this was our
first real introduction where we we got
to know you and this was about two years
ago and since then your channels have
just or your channel and you're just
following everything off of every
platform has just exploded and
especially tick tock where you how many
followers do you have at this point um
it's 2.7 million but it should be
rolling up like any moment now to 2.8
million which is insane because it's
just the viral growth i've seen on tick
tock is just crazy compared because the
first real viral video i had on tick
tock it was the um the magic penny one
where i took the briefcase full of cash
and then showed what happens if you take
a penny and you double it every day for
29 days birthday it was like a four-part
video which is insane
and i uploaded that and within three
days of memory session right had 20
million views in the whole series and i
was like what the crap why would anybody
watch a 59 second video and i'm like
this is basic math but granted i have
the aspect i've got a briefcase with a
bunch of money in it um i mean i can get
a little bit of attention that way but
it's just the viral growth was there i
was like holy crap this is insane and
then you know just kept going on with my
regular collection videos regular cycle
and just started just continuing on with
it and it's been insane and it's just so
weird because i get stopped i
when i blew up the rumor was with tiktok
that everybody was a bot like 90 of your
traffic was bots
and there was just this rumor i'm like
no one's really real and then i got
stopped at walmart
and someone's like it's the laundromat
guy
i'm like yeah you watch me on youtube
like you're on youtube
why where did you see me oh i saw you on
tick tock me and my all my friends watch
on tik tok and i'm like oh my gosh
they're not bots i can't believe this is
a really surreal moment
like oh wow here's this new platform it
was you know relatively new generally
speaking and i've got all this viral
traffic off of people recognizing who i
am and i'm like and i prefer them to be
on youtube but i'll take what i can get
it's interesting we had zach king on a
few days ago and he was talking about
that he was on youtube and then his tick
tock is what's turning out to be like
more popular in terms of followers and
people will come up to him having no
idea that he is a youtube channel yeah
you just know him from tick tock
90 of the people that i talk to that
watch me on tick tock have no clue i'm
on youtube
so there is almost no intermeshing and i
was talking to ask said i was talking
about assembly like a couple hours ago
and i was like there's no intermeshing
because he was talking to a couple other
creators on tik tok and they said that
they just tick-tock traffic sucks
because no one will go to your youtube
channel like tick-tock traffic doesn't
suck because there's attention there you
got influence over people but the
problem is they don't want to pull
people off your platform like everybody
knows youtube wants to keep all your
views inside the youtube platform and
tiktok is like twice as bad they want to
keep all your traffic in browser so
guess what happens you go to youtube on
the in tik tok browser you can't
subscribe you have to log into your
youtube account from tick tock it's just
practically impossible because you have
to go through the google authentication
i had no idea that's interesting yeah
it's it's very very difficult because
i've found people that i want to
subscribe to on um
from tiktok and it's just this
mess so i copy and paste their name from
tiktok into youtube so i can subscribe
to them and then what you have to end up
doing i mean there's a whole other
procedure you have to do with it but
it's just one of those odd things that i
run into because i'm like well and i run
into people that are arguing and
throwing a fit over i'm like well just
use the traffic that you have on the
platform there's i mean you have a
million subscribers on there you can
make all the money you need to if you
run
treat it like a business why don't we go
back to the very beginning how do you
get involved in doing all of this do you
have a degree
okay tell us tell us the back story you
were the 30 second sales pitch do you
want the five minutes
how about the five minute one
five minutes okay so give us some five
minute version okay so my name is
brandon i grew up 20 miles south of
columbus my dad was a truck driver my
mom sold avon
um grew up in a us outside of a little
town called circleville um ohio we're
famous for pumpkins we all worship
pumpkins
anyway um so my dad drove truck my mom
sold avon we were always really dirt
poor when six years old we got evicted
um we had we ended up moving to the
literally the middle of a cornfield my
parents were able to find a house that
they could kind of afford uh lived there
for quite some time um
then long story short my dad had a heart
attack
when i thought it was 18 um we lost that
house we got evicted out of that second
house
with my dad's heart attack he just was
he couldn't work anymore so my brother
and i we had to go immediately go get
jobs i started working up at a warehouse
in grove port ohio um just like an
amazon warehouse because i i talk very
favorably about working for amazon
because all these people i've talked to
a lot of people on social media like oh
i just work at amazon warehouse or i
work at a fulfillment center i'm like
hey i did that for three years so i
worked at fulfill uh fulfillment center
for three years uh my brother picked
trash for the city municipality um so
did that for three years and then i was
like you know i'll never be able to
raise a family on this i need to find
out something that i can do um that i
could support a family and i've always
had this dream of having a one-income
household it's typically you know any
more modern society have a two two
income household husband and wife work
it's hard to raise a family and all that
different stuff so i'm like you know i i
think if i do i get a real estate
license
and even in my small town you know this
is 15 plus years ago everybody that was
in real estate drove a cadillac and they
had nice clothes i'm like well hey even
in my small town they've got cadillac so
everybody in real estate must be rich so
i ended up spending three weeks three
whole weeks going and getting my real
estate license so that was 2006
and then after got real estate i came to
the really quick determination that the
sales people there were a few that were
wealthy
but it was practically all investors
that were wealthy i ran into a janitor
of a hospital in columbus and he was a
janitor
and he came to my office and this is
like 0.708 i got my license to know six
and he's like i need to buy i want to
buy some getaway land down on the hills
i'm like okay whatever you know that's
fine go get uh pre-qualified for a
mortgage and he's like what do you mean
by i said go get pre-qualified for a
mortgage and we can talk about what you
can afford blah blah blah and he throws
a freaking checkbook at me and he said
look at it like okay what and i open up
this guy's checkbook that he threw at me
take a look he has half a million
dollars in his checking account and i'm
like what the heck did you do you're a
janitor and he said i invest in real
estate
and i'm like you invest in real estate
he said yeah i buy houses close to the
hospital and we flip them
and i'm like oh my gosh i don't need to
be a real estate agent i need to be an
investor so from 07 ish i spent from 07
to 2013 just like try figure how do i
get money to invest and there's a lot of
other stuff that went on i got into
building websites and online marketing
and stuff
while i kept having my real estate
license i got in big into selling
foreclosures doing bank bank bpos uh
broker price opinions for banks doing
foreclosures ran a foreclosure blog that
was decently popular for a while
um
all trying to figure out how do i get
money to buy rentals and i just couldn't
do it because i just kept getting more
money but i couldn't go and buy anything
but first i want to thank our sponsor
start engine alex do you know what i'm
super excited about this holiday season
that you get to eat an entire
thanksgiving turkey by yourself and
nobody's gonna judge you for it no
well yeah but is it the thing that you
told me not to talk about in the podcast
what are you talking about man there was
nothing there oh well is it our sponsor
today start engine yes alex it is you
see i've been so interested in startups
and equity crowdfunding but the problem
is for a long time those investments
have been reserved for accredited
investors with huge net worths but times
are changing and now they are way more
accessible you know what jack that
sounds awesome and i think something
like that would really add a new level
of diversity to my portfolio and with
over 600 000 users and 450 million
dollars raised i think start engine
could be a good starting point not to
mention it's shark approved kevin
o'leary aka mr wonderful himself is
actually a strategic advisor an investor
and a paid spokesperson of start engine
plus the ceo howard marks was a
co-founder of activision which has a
multi-billion dollar market cap so their
team is pretty impressive so click the
link in the description to get started
today and start engine will send you an
article that details five things
investors should know before they invest
in their first startup and you can get
started diversifying your portfolio
today thank you so much start engine for
sponsoring this episode and back to the
podcast
throughout 2013 i finally figured out
you know i can go out and get investors
i can go out and get capital a different
way and at that point i was able to go
get investors and then we just kind of
meandered on
um
picked up the landlord from when i was
six years old the one that evicted me um
he became one of my investors and we
started buying more property and all
that stuff so
um in that process i started in 2013
bought a house july 2013 i think about
two in 2013 four or five and 20 14.
um then i just kept scaling and every
year i've got more except
i think 20 20 i only bought
i didn't buy anything in 2020 i don't
think i bought anything in 2020 which is
weird because i figured if i was going
to have growth on youtube channel i'd
just be constantly buying properties and
yeah right and showing people what it's
like and
i've bought less stuff since i started
like really doing well on youtube than
i've ever done so that's what i'm trying
to hopefully get back to is buying more
stuff i mean
we've got the laundromat and i did buy
the two car washes but
it's just been an odd thing i bought
like a vending machine here and i bought
an arcade machine here and i'm like you
know i really want to go and buy another
apartment complex or i want to go and
buy some
different kinds of real estate that i
want to always wanted to try and dabble
my hands and i just can cross monetize
it with youtube
and that's kind of where i want to go
but it's just been a slow process
because of coronavirus because i've at
up until recently essentially
self-managed everything which is a it's
been a nightmare during chronovirus
how many doors do you have at the moment
uh it's like 138 or 139 and if you were
to buy currently would you use investor
money still or would you just use your
own funds um it depends if like right
now i'm still once in a while taking
capital and it's usually because i want
to try and build a relationship with
somebody if i like i've got
well the landlord evicted me i want
access to a little more money so i
called him oh gosh what was that call
like like hey uh you you evicted you
evicted us
can i get some money he called me he did
yes he did he said i've seen that you're
really good with money and he said i
know that you don't know me very well
but he said if the next time you've got
a deal give me a call so i was like two
or three months later i was like really
am i going to let this guy back in my
life i was like you know if i would sit
down and analyze why somebody would
evict my family i thought
i'm not saying i would've my family but
i'm like i sure as heck would not have
done what my parents wanted to do
because they wanted a no money down land
contract with no credit
like i would never do that in a million
years as an investor and my parents for
some reason thought that you could do
that you can't do that if they really
wanted the house that we got evicted out
of they should have got qualified for a
mortgage totally would have gone usda
they could have put five down five
percent down in the 1990s and they could
have bought it they could have done it
but instead the landlord needed cash you
wanted to sell the house out so he
evicted us it's like it's just it's a
logical procedure all that all this
business stuff is a logical procedure
and if you are in the driver's seat it
makes sense 90 of the time there's a
disconnect between your average person i
think and the person that's in business
because you're never in the driver's
seat for the money and the finances and
sometimes you just have to make hard
choices i make art i have to make hard
choices practically every day at least
every week within my business of who
gets qualified who doesn't get qualified
where am i going to take this money what
am i going to do with it and you know
sometimes there's just no good choice
just to have to make a choice and let
the chips fall what they want to so
wow so um
at what point did you start getting into
car washes laundromats arcades
um
and why
so the laundromat that i own right now
was one that me and a buddy tried to buy
back in 2018
and um
with the the guy that owned it the uh
trippy um
the guy that um owned it before i did he
passed away in 2017 and his mom took
over the estate as an executor we tried
to talk her into doing
selling us the laundromat and we offered
like 50 grand and she didn't want to do
it because she thought i didn't have the
money and this is 2018 i could have
wrote her a check i could have bought it
you know paid her cash and she didn't
want to do it she went with somebody
else and as a part of that process we
got the books on it we saw that she was
turning in 8 500 worth of quarters a
month to the bank no yeah and i mean it
was to the point that she couldn't bear
she
like taken him in little buckets and all
this different stuff and i was like holy
freaking crap that's a 50 50 000
property like i don't care what i have
to deal with headache-wise i'm the roi
on that's extremely economical it's like
a one-year repay
so
i didn't get it she went with another
investor um the other investor could not
make a run of it um why
just um he outsourced all of the
business process to a family member
which i have found out the hard way does
not work in a lot of cases
he outsourced the entirety of the
business process to family member they
ran into the ground tour wasn't making
any money they closed it down for a year
and a half ish and then i took it over
or
i bought two other laundromats that were
absolute failures um and we've
liquidated one of them we're in the
process i'm actually land contracting it
to a guy that works for me because he
doesn't want to use it as a laundromat
now that i know
a lot more about laundromats i never
would have bought those two but looking
at the the one that was making 8 500
a month i was like oh man like these
things are cash cows so i bought two
other laundromats and they didn't work
out too well but i could see the numbers
as i did resource i'm like man i buy one
good laundromat it'll make those other
two crap deals work out so i got this
the guy that owned it was selling it
and
i convinced him to sell it to me with
seller financing in place so i didn't
get it for the 50k that i offered but i
got it for 15k down and then he's
carrying back 75 000 on a really good
note
so
um and it's just it's worked out really
really well and we've gone through we've
renovated it we got a laundry consultant
guy danny
he's he flew into ohio because of my
youtube channel and kind of went through
the whole laundromat and said hey you've
you you suck go and do
set up this process for your laundromat
and now
um i just did my last video we the first
nine days of this month we brought in
three grand so it's not attracted to
what no what do you do what did you walk
in what was bad about it he is big on
like all new machines make it look
really nice and clean and get new
machines and that's that's kind of the
big thing of it yeah what more could a
laundry consultant really do
not to discredit me a laundry consultant
let me educate you jack really quick
because uh what was interesting when you
called in on our first conversation was
because i
seriously looked at getting a laundromat
i think it was 2014 or 15.
and i really considered it and uh i
found there was a laundromat forum
and a whole bunch of people were giving
advice on how to find laundromats and
then through that there was everyone
recommended a laundromat consultant
and uh i met with a guy and he walked us
through one of his laundromats that he
like i i don't want to say like he
managed it but he helped put it together
it was a night it was a nice place but
everything from like right when you walk
in how does the flow look like where do
you put the security camera what type of
machines do you use where's the like the
the dollar thing is there a restroom on
site does the door lock at a certain
hour automatically do you have it's
insane but i almost got uh after that
that that consultation with him i almost
felt like i know nothing
first we have to thank our sponsor
ritual guys let me tell you about my
morning ritual i wake up at precisely 6
49 a.m every single day i get out of bed
brush my teeth for approximately 2.1
minutes and then i jump for joy because
why not i then walk down my 15 steps to
get downstairs and then get ready to
head to the gym but before i go to the
gym i have to have my daily protein
shake and that is exactly where our
sponsor ritual comes in some protein
powders can seem super intimidating and
sometimes that ingredients list can seem
super confusing but with ritual you get
a delicious plant-based protein offered
in three premium formulations for
different stages of life that require
different nutritional needs and it's all
made with the same high standards
approach and commitment for traceability
that ritual is known for so whether
you're doing reps or walking the dog
there's something for you so why not
shake up your ritual today and to make
trying something new less scary ritual
offers a 100 money back guarantee if
you're not fully satisfied and our
listeners can actually get 10 off their
first three months by going to
ritual.com slash ich that's ritual.com
ich go ahead try them out guys thank you
rachel for sponsoring this episode and
back to the podcast
like you you would think that it's easy
yeah but i was
uh it was the amount of work and i
looked into it and believe it or not
like remember i i would tell all the
time that uh before i got into real
estate i would go to open houses like
every single weekend for months guess
what i went to laundromats and i would
go with a with a buddy of mine and we'd
go together and we just like
every single laundromat we'd walk in and
just look around to see like what was
good what was bad and uh you learn a lot
from that but it's a it's a business
and uh you can't hire it out
and it's very hard to do
and that's the thing that i'm finding
out it's just how bad i am at finding
good people but it's something that i'm
very conscientiously trying to
concentrate on and solve within my own
business because i've got we're to the
point that i can either blow up my
social media stuff and make way more
money with it or i can blow up my
real estate business side of it i'm
trying to
i'm trying to do what i can to make sure
things are segmented right so i can make
the most profitable choice for me and
it'll probably be social media for
honestly now what did the laundromat guy
do though for your business what did he
say what was his advice um
get rid of all my crap machines because
we were constantly having one two three
machines down constantly and he said
look no one uses a laundromat that
always has machines down you got to have
everything working the only way to do
that is get all new machines and the
problem is with laundromats is
one machine could retail for twenty
thousand dollars it's like oh you need
twenty of these machines it's like
twenty machines at twenty thousand
dollars is a piece it's 400 grand like i
don't want to spend that money and he's
got a really good system of this is what
you offer this is how you negotiate to
get those machines here's how you can
get them financed from the factory
like with very minimal money he helps
you negotiate leases he helps you just
do all these different things because
unlike my situation in southern ohio i i
won't buy something unless i own the
dirt underneath it i want to buy the
real estate i want to own the land
that is very much not normal in the
united states most are in least
facilities and you guys know i'm sure
lisa you can get screwed over on at
least six way from sunday especially in
the state of california because what
they'll do is they'll break
like community fees water fees there's
like all these different
like they would be like hoa fees in ohio
but there are other like cam fees and
just all this different stuff and then
they
they make you think that you're getting
an all-inclusive price on the lease and
then you find out there's all these
backup fees and so your lease just goes
from 5000 to 10 000 just at the drop of
a hat and he comes in and helps you get
a really really good lease on the
property so if you you've got a 20-year
lease on a property and you've you're
only getting like a one percent
acceleration a month or a year and your
landlord initially asked for six
you know you start figuring out what the
in dollar amount is after 20 years it's
just an insane difference and a lot of
people just don't understand that that's
kind of things that can happen so how
much do you think this consultant saved
you and how much did they charge
they didn't charge me anything because
my youtube channel which is nice wow
yeah so you want to plug them may as
well plug them it's danny d'angelo i'm
going to his house tomorrow so like
right after i record this we're gonna go
do a live stream tomorrow cool so i
brought all my camera gear is he in
vegas no he's in phoenix oh i got
excited for a second i'm sorry he could
be in vegas he lives in phoenix and he
comes to vegas with his wife like all
the freaking time what's interesting to
me is that you're a finance youtuber and
tick-tocker and you have a huge
following but at the same time
you are very very smart with investing
and i think you could be the only
finance youtuber that makes well like
real genuine finance youtuber that makes
more money from your investments and
your non like youtube job than you do
from youtube
oh we need to hear this let's what do
you think graham how much oh wait okay
you know what i'm gonna guess oh please
don't uh i'll guess uh social media are
we we're counting everything so
including sponsorships and everything
i'm gonna guess social media probably
pull in forty thousand dollars a month
on that
i'm gonna say 30. all right you're gonna
say three i was gonna see there
oh you tell us that first probably about
25.
you're closer dude yeah because the
youtubers are killing me they're killing
my long format content
and that's going to happen for a while
and i've kind of resigned myself to the
fact that my shorts are going to hurt my
long format content and adsense income
for a while until i either back in
people and i get them in a sales funnel
and do something else with the traffic
or i wait till youtube fixes their
shorts and then all the delicious money
starts coming back
so i think 30 well that's what i said 30
for the social stuff and then for your
you know non-social media stuff i think
you're probably making 45 or 50.
no i think uh
i'm gonna guess
um we're talking net
can we talk
oh so i don't even know that number
because i'm spending so much on capex
right now yeah so i'm
gross gross has to be about 150 but i'm
gonna guess of that net in your pocket
has got to be about 80.
uh yeah this one is a little high it's
like i'm in the like vicinity of 100 120
gross
and then if i wasn't spending so much on
capex it should be like 50 60 a month um
net and that's with all the things i'm
in and then i've got some partnership
agreements where i don't get the whole
thing and then my debt service i pay
like 17 000 a month of debt service but
a lot of it's amortizing and we're
getting close on several loans just
closing them out so then my monthly
net's going to drop increase more but
suffice to say my net's probably two to
three times a month on my investments
versus my youtube income
but the thing is it's like with my my
social media stuff i spend no time on it
my time commitment's almost next to
nothing um
other than editing i i spent i spent no
time on shooting my content half of it's
with my cell phone
incredible to me because when i watch
your videos it's like you've done
everything right from what because when
i'm talking to zach zack king
he's he told us that he does like 90
takes on his stuff it's really it's
planned out everything you see is
purposeful and like he
gets the i don't say he gets the
algorithm down but he knows exactly what
to do which points to
to make it work yeah but yours is just
like yeah i'm just going to film with my
iphone spend the time and that's that's
where i've got to i've got to resign
myself to that's how my content is
always going to look and now i'm trying
to figure out what does the
systemization of that look like and
realistically it's going to be someone
following me around with a camera once
or one or two days a week
and just doing all the stuff they're
going to edit it on the back end make it
look authentic because it will be
authentic
and then hopefully i'll get to the point
that i'll be getting out the volume of
content that i need because i'm lacking
severely in the volume i would like uh i
would like ideally to have four short
cut format a week and then three long
format contents of content a week i'd
agree with that if i can film for 16 to
18 hours a week then i'll be good and
then just outsource all the editing
which is where i'm going
now my ultimate goal is to do the whole
thing live
because i really really like kevin's
engagement
i've
partially stalked kevin on
his stats for youtube and i know what
engagement he's at i've talked to a
couple people about that do live streams
and they've said yeah you know if you
would do structured live streams you
would get about 10x what you do now i
can pull in
6 700 concurrents on just a random live
stream at a random live stream the other
night of the laundromat because i had to
go fix something i just turned on my
cell phone had 700 concurrents and 18
000 watchers um over the 45 minute
stream which was good and the see
youtube's increases see the rpm rate for
live streams a ton
so i get the good engagement it goes out
to my youtube shorts followers
and it's just going to work out really
well so if i could figure out like a
multi-cam format live stream i think
that'll be exactly what i want and if we
can do it in high enough quality then we
just can go and we can take all the
content i need get the episodic stuff
and then just get it out but i like the
idea of having a live stream that poor
people can ask questions like
why are you doing this thing brandon why
are you weighing the quarters in a
bucket that's because if i did it with
machine it would take me an hour and a
half and i can do this other thing in
five minutes it's more time efficient
for me how accurate can you get when you
weigh quarters like that oh my gosh it's
real it's really close within one
percent exactly
yeah i use my machine because i have to
separate quarters nickels and dimes
and
plus it's fine i like the sound and when
you go to a bank with like a bucket full
of quarters do you hate me do you wrap
it up you don't wrap it up oh no i
specifically went through every bank in
my county figured out who would let me
drink bring in the ball coins
so how do they do but then they have to
wrap it no they've no you know they've
got a deal if they can get it to a
accurate amount amount they can give it
to bring so loomis and they'll take it
to the federal depository because we've
got a federal federal depository in
cleveland which is really that far from
me so they take a bulk bag it has 1 250
worth of quarters in it and they just
put in the bulk bag throw in the but but
they have to still count out the fed
does the 1250 the fed does it that does
that's why we have a quarter shortage
right now because these banks take our
coin shortage they take the fed bags
they take them to the depository and
they're so far behind on counting those
quarters and they're not bringing enough
surplus or enough enough volume from the
mint and new
new coins that we have a short i didn't
know that yeah i had no idea either why
don't so here's the thing i've always
believed that they should get rid of
change
uh well how how do you feel about that
like at least get rid of the penny yeah
get rid of the pen we don't need that
but also it's like
usually change just don't
at some point i think it's going to be
just a tap card like a credit card it's
a chip in your hand
you just scan it
credits yeah yeah so that social credit
thing is
um
i i think that probably in 20 years
you'll probably see
coins like they are disappear
but you you'd be shocked the
municipalities in areas that are very
very strict they absolutely want change
new york city is one of them and as many
digs as i have against new york city
they kind of demand that laundromats and
other businesses like that accept
quarters and money they don't want to go
tap to pay because there's a lot of
people that are on ssi and stuff they
absolutely don't want to use a card they
want to use cash so it's kind of like a
disenfranchisement deal if you don't
accept cash at a business
um since you know legally it is you know
they have to accept that tinder there's
ways to kind of there's some flexibility
on those laws but i i would like to see
i guess probably
rounding up to
a nickel
um rather than just doing away with all
change and then just go to five cent and
20 cent coins but you don't really have
to like bring a bunch of quarters to the
bank because what i find funny for some
reason i just find this so so hilarious
is that people will go in with dollars
and then they'll put it in the machine
and then they'll get quarters out and
then they'll spend quarters in the
laundromat and then you cycle those
quarters in the laundromat back into the
machine where they put their dollars in
yeah so it's literally just how many of
you spent the same quarters yeah
i just laid it at night it hasn't kept
me up late i think it's so funny that
the quarters literally just go from the
machine to the laundromat or to the
laundry machines back to the machine
until my competitor comes in with
hundred dollars and 20s and tries to run
me out of change
no
oh you know what i want to hear about
the dirty talk about the drama it's the
dirty tricks believe it or not i've
heard so many stories
laundromat owners are ruthless there was
one story that i heard and this was on
the forums by the way okay and this was
like the top the top yeah the laundromat
forums
uh the top thread was about a guy uh
someone wanted to put their savings into
a laundromat they thought they'd done
all the research and some guy wrote like
this essay on why he shouldn't do it and
one of the reasons was that uh there was
there was one owner of a laundromat who
had like six or seven of them in this
one like big it was a big enough city
and he had like the monopoly on this
well
someone else opened up a laundromat in
his territory
and he didn't like it so what he ended
up doing is lowering the price of all of
his laundromats oh yeah uh to basically
run this person out of business
and so what happened is uh apparently
the the the guy was warned if you open
up here i'm doing this don't open up
here and then i was like no it's you
know how bad could it be the guy
literally ran him out of business just
by lowering his prices and the guy was
like listen i have all the money in the
world you you like it's gonna hurt you
more than it's gonna hurt me sure i
don't care if i don't make money for a
year but you're going out of business
yeah and sure enough uh nobody went
there yeah i mean there's dirty tricks
in that yeah let's hear them i want to
yeah what's the drama in the laundromat
i mean
car washes too i mean oh well we'll get
to that let's be honest it's about any
business where
you've got people potentially with old
money
that can just just be mean and be angry
at people
i mean
what isn't there you go and pay a
oh gosh i don't want to get demonetized
like uh we'll be curious i don't know if
you guys watch my channel i call them
people of the rock
because we can't use that word
on youtube we get demonetized you don't
watch any of my stuff do you people with
the rock people that use a certain kind
of rock in their life that's an illicit
substance so acidics yes of a substance
okay yes yes so so i mean there's
it's nothing to give somebody a hundred
bucks and ask them to go down burn down
somebody else's laundry no
i mean gosh you guys
so you're saying you don't deal with
competition so you're saying you're
saying you're saying people that are
addicted to substances
they'll do anything for money to get
more of the substance they will be paid
by your competitors yeah
to burn down laundromats car washes yeah
sure
that is absurd and why laundromats out
of all things is it profitable
i mean but let's go back to what i said
starting off this this leg here is
people with old money can
they get to this point that you've got
all this money
and you can spend on whatever you want
your you've done had a lot of matter for
30 or 40 years and some whippersnapper
comes into town and they they're trying
to take over your business and you can
just spend money to the point that they
go bankrupt or you can pay somebody to
do something they shouldn't be doing or
you can go you there's there's all sorts
of ways you can do it and i'm not saying
let me be clear i'm not saying this
happens very often but it does happen
and it's but it's just it's with any
kind of business that's out there that
you have people with old money and those
i've seen with rentals i've seen people
under price they're almost 200 300 bucks
a month because someone bought a
property they didn't like
so what are the other tricks though you
mentioned putting a hundred dollar bills
and running out of change
oh i i've i'm sure that i've had people
come and intentionally damage my
equipment i don't know for certain that
is a competitor but it's just and you
know and what's so funny is people it's
not just with laundromats people have
like they are a big brand supporter of a
competitor and so you know if they
accidentally throw
i don't know
rags enough dryer with oil on them and
it accidentally sets it on fire you know
there's people that'll support a brand
and they'll just damage equipment that's
crazy
you people if someone goes a laundromat
for 20 or 30 years the same one and they
kind of come to the decision that the
other person is going to put them out of
business the one they've been using for
20 30 years that's the same side of town
might as well go break the crap that is
customer loyalty if i've ever seen it
before gosh that's
what about car washes i mean unless
there's anything else in the laundry but
i'm i still rock my mind like i said i
at the onset of this i can go for like
five hours
more of these stories what i've seen is
on your instagram and i think also your
youtube videos you have security cameras
that catch the wildest things oh yeah
happening in your laundromat can you can
you provide like maybe like the craziest
thing that happened in your laundromat
or maybe two months
say it say it well just say in like the
the kid version
if there's a way when a mommy and daddy
love each other very much
i don't understand
i'm jack
jack's parents never uh okay okay oh
they watched this gram they watched this
um i've had that happen a couple times
i've had
people concoct substances on the floor
like they were cutting their materials
with
with credit cards and debit cards on the
floor yeah but not the high quality
stuff like the cheap stuff
um i've had those two i have i've had a
lot of people like throw a party in my
laundry bag
i absolutely laugh they come in with
like a 12 pack or 24 pack beer isn't
that almost like a
good thing like doesn't that help i mean
like
you know that's kind of one of those
situations i'm like is this a bad thing
or a good thing because they really like
my laundromat i was about to say laundry
party did they do laundry or do they
just go and party some of both they just
kind of go i would be happy with that
like if someone came in with with a
six-pack with their buddies and like at
least one of them is doing laundry yeah
and and
customers are not turned off by that or
they're welcoming that would be a
memorable experience
that's that's been funny those are kind
of my more memorable things um the one
that's i still get anger angry at is we
had to put a um
quick set key code on our bathroom so
now you have to call a number to get the
code to use the bathroom we had to do
that and i don't i've never talked about
this on the channel so it's oh what's
the grand stafford
hit the like button and subscribe for
this yeah so
we put the lock on it because i found
out later on at some point probably in
the past year that people were going
into my bathroom and they were hiding
baggies of illicit substances in our in
our drop drop down ceiling and they were
popping out the panels hiding it up
there and then someone was coming back
later and they were like cash happening
each other because someone's like oh
yeah they're key shopping each other for
the the substances they're hiding up in
your drop ceiling
wow i wouldn't even think about that i
would you know why not anywhere else in
a park
anywhere else
no cameras guaranteed not in the
bathroom yeah i got them in the hallway
i got them all over the laundromat
people know i even got the the security
cameras wired up to tv so when you walk
in the laundromat you see yourself on
the camera they still did it
and i'm like oh my gosh so if i would
have known it
because we figured this out when we were
renovating the laundromat if i would
have known that i would have taken a
live stream camera and i would have hid
it above the drop ceiling with a light
trigger on it because it would have been
i would have got yes i would have got a
notification on it
um and
so is that illegal no no not there no in
the state of ohio we're a one-party
wiretap state and it's great because
what it means is as long as there is an
expectation and by uh as my
understanding of a legal expert under
ohio revised code it essentially says if
you there is no expectation of privacy
then none is afforded so if you're at a
business unless you are in the bathroom
the confines the bathroom then there's
no privacy expected so it's anywhere in
the grounds of laundromat i can do
whatever i want to with recording so
it's like really you expect privacy in
the drop ceiling uh you can't see
anything else we set the camera up so
that's all i get is the hand
up there and it's just but the the
problem is is do i want this drama and
this spite to drive my content or do i
want to be the happy guy with the
quarters that's the problem because
if you get on the wrong side of that
like let's say because it's not just the
guy it's the guy who then gets it from
somebody else who gets it from somebody
else and that top person is like who's
this guy and why does this have 20
million views and why is my guy's hand
on there yeah in my business and then
all of a sudden then you become a target
of that yeah and it's just it's just i
you know if i if i let it all the drama
and the problems will overwhelm me and
overwhelm the channel and it's like i
cut back on a lot of the drama it's
going back to this having a cameraman
following me around both good and bad
stuff i only like put like i figured it
was like 20 of it on youtube and tick
tock like i've got 80 more stuff that i
was like man it's like for instance
right before i came here we did a craft
show with my my 10 year old and 12 year
old they baked bread they made chocolate
and they took it to this craft show and
they were there for like an hour hour
and a half they sold eight dollars and i
said you know what guys you know it
would be fun and they said what i said
me to show you guys how daddy sells
things and they said what do you mean i
said all right i said i want you to fill
up a basket with all your bread and all
your different stuff and i said we're
gonna go sit make some money
and they said okay so they made eight
dollars in an hour and a half and so i
said and they said my 12 year i said or
my i took my 10 year old first and she
said so how are we going to make money
we're not selling anything i said we're
up to every single person in this
building and say hi i'm brandon's
daughter and
uh me and my sister baked bread for this
past week and we made homemade
chocolates would you please buy some
i made 80 bucks an hour doing that yeah
yeah and i'm like and it was very
uncomfortable for him i was like guys
this is daddy's job this when daddy goes
daddy sells something we're all at some
point in our life going to be we're
either selling our time to an employer
or we're selling a product to somebody
it's all life comes down to selling your
time selling a product
um
and i'm like this is what daddy does and
we just had an absolute blast at a
craft show selling homemade bread and
chocolate and my kids made enough money
and they're like they came home and like
mommy we got enough money buy switch now
each my kids can you know now afford a
switch because i'm a cheapskate and
won't buy them stuff anyway um so it's
like we didn't record anything for it
just it's lost the time
except the stories so i got the story so
that's nice and i could do the stories
but good i like that will you please buy
some because it's it's
conveying the message they're asking for
it politely and it's hard to say no to
that yeah can you please buy some
it's instead of would you like to buy
some no would you please buy something
yeah and
see that little shift there yeah yeah
it's smart because especially coming
from a kid it's like you can't say that
as like an older person but from a kid
it's like you can kind of demand that
yeah right because it's an innocent
thing well we're guilty men it's it's
it's exploiting their
i look at all the kids that do lemonade
stands i love kids that do lemonade
stands but i also feel bad for them
because a lot of them are bad at sales
they just don't know what they're doing
and it's like i wish that every kid that
have a lemonade stand would know how to
sell because man that would be a great
point to start off your life and
just considering the possibility of
having a career that deals with sales
i've done so many lemonade stands and
the hardest part is getting people to
stop their car
yeah but then that kind of can be a
location thing and it can kind of be a
logistical thing you know if you could
go up to the cars and sell it then it
might be more
um advantageous i did a youtube video
forever we parked cars for our big
festival or from where i'm from
and my brandon's great idea was you know
what we should go get a bunch of stripe
readers for our cell phones so we can
take cards so we're the only parking lot
in the whole entire town that would take
credit cards
and all the people that were working for
me during that festival they're like
this is the smartest thing ever i'm like
kind of stupid that no one thought that
you can get a cardboard for five bucks
and you know we made extra thousand
dollars let's say just for a five dollar
swipe swipe reader that we got from
walmart it's just those kind of little
tweaks and that's kind of hopefully
i feel like about it do a bad job
presenting it on my youtube channel
there's all these little tweaks and
little things that you can do
in a business that improves your margin
you think that you you
my thing that i always try to do is
look at something figure out what the
average is
increase your sales 10 or 20 over the
median or whatever the average is and
try to decrease your um expenses 10 or
20 percent if you could just take any
business like with someone has a 10 cap
rate or an eight cap rate you drop your
expenses 20 you increase your sales 20
those numbers start to become super
super powerful especially if you
leverage it i ran into a guy that did a
spec construction in my town on a
chipotle and he sold it at a three
percent cap rate i thought i'm in a
small town in ohio why would anybody buy
a commercial facility on three percent
cap rate they said you know they've got
a 3.5 percent yearly acceleration clause
and they got a 20-year guaranteed lease
from chipotle which is backed by
mcdonald's you start penciling those
numbers it's like 75 percent increase
and
in the
gross rent rate
over the next
12 years or so it's just incredible the
way the numbers start working
and a lot of people don't take that math
back and think oh wow i just have to do
a little better
on my sales are a little better on my
expenses and you can rule the world with
it and there's just so many businesses
that could take that efficiency gain
but you know people need to be
encouraged to have a
feel like they can do it that he tends
to be like
smart man very smart man i don't know
about that what what see the dumb stuff
i do
i would love to hear about the dumbbells
tell us about the dumb stuff
oh uh when i was six years old or seven
years old i felt like
i needed to retire on my gi joes in an
honorable way so i poured a bunch of
gasoline on them and i went and got my
dad's bow and arrow wrapped a rag full
of gasoline around it and shot the
flaming arrow into the
big stack of g.i joe toys i missed had
to go get the
the flaming arrow back up i went up to
the big giant pile of toys with gasoline
on it and found out the hard way that
vapors get generated from that and i
woke up unconscious under a tree missing
my eyebrows i blame that on that's one
of the reasons i think i'm bald today
that's probably it
that's i could rattle off more that is
like less than stellar intelligence but
i don't even know what to say what's
your favorite business to run
i don't know
i like the car washes they're pretty fun
what about the stories of the car washes
like this shady stuff in car wash we've
heard laundromats
i mean
uh it's the same the big thing is and i
i i'm gonna get hate mail is so many of
these businesses
people are under reporting their income
to the irs i mean
it's assumed with laundromats i mean
yeah but especially
but grocery stores and car washes and
laundromats and vending machines a lot
of people under report their income some
like severely
and what bugs the heck out of me is when
you go in to buy one and you're like i
want to offer you x y z amount of
dollars and they're like okay i'm like
can you give me a tax return because i
want to go get sba financing or i want
to take it to a bank
and they're like well there's a problem
we don't have any money you know and you
have nothing to show so
you you end up at this point i make this
point on a lot of my videos number one
to get the irs off my back
created that hasn't been too successful
because i did get audited last year
but it's over bitcoin so it's all happy
so
um
but they under report their income yeah
and
then it comes time to sell they lose so
much equity in the business if they
would have just properly reported and
get a good cpa that'll help them do cost
segmentation
track their depreciation appropriately
expense things that are are appropriate
to provide corporate perks that you can
take a lot of different things off your
taxes i mean you take any
was a 1065 statement to from your
self-employment or business income
statement you take it to bank the first
thing they do is they take off
depreciation
so if you can get that depreciation
number up high enough to minimize your
tax liability you're good good as gold
you don't have to worry about it i i
dealt with one of them because we got a
statement from one laundromat and the
same thing and the the guy who we
had helping us said that it was so
common just basically don't ask for a
tax return it's not going to be accurate
instead what he recommended doing was
hiring somebody to track
what sort of business they were doing
over the course of a week or it was like
over a month or something and you
extrapolate based off that yeah and you
can do you can do back end engineering
on water reports you can go
like scan the barcodes for all the
washers in the facility you can pull a
pdf file from the manufacturer of it you
can say oh this washer uses 45 gallons
per cycle well
um
you come with a median figure and takes
like 10 minutes to do a spreadsheet call
the water department because it's most
states have a law that you can request
water
water statements on everybody and then
you just kind of do the algebra on the
back end and figure out how many cycles
they've run
look at their median prices and you can
get it it was it was interesting because
i remember
at the time this was 2013 or 14 there
was a big difference or there's starting
to be a shift between the coin operated
machines and the card operated machines
and
i remember his advice being stick with
the coins because if you get audited uh
there's less of a trail
yeah
and and it seemed like people were also
very resistant to doing the card
machines yes because it's it's trackable
it seems like a lot of people in that
industry were like we just want the cash
and still that way with a lot of people
but yeah but the big thing is if you
take cards and you do a rewards program
then you can collect a float
and people oh yeah cards and i've heard
some numbers thrown out there and
they're
add one person i
i don't trust what they say but they
said they had a 20 float
on the redemptions for the laundromat
wow that would
and it would be so worth it if you had a
20 float on your laundry bank cards or
car wash cards right i haven't heard
that number thrown around ever for a car
wash i've heard like a 10 float on car
wash um reaction codes
but tell us about the the shady stories
or or funny stories with car wash i like
your stories
i like the worst one that we've gone
through is someone intentionally ramming
our car wash and
it was
like it's probably we don't know what
the insurance number is going to be but
it's going to be six figures probably a
hundred under twenty yeah
like how does that work yeah they their
machine was stopped someone had bumped
it with a pickup truck because it can
only the old machine that we had in
there can only take
vehicles up to 19 feet no one knows how
long do you know
you own a vehicle right jack yes i do
okay how how long is it
16 feet
no that's 16. do you realize how big 16
feet is that's a pickup truck size how
long is it
graham your car
i'm guessing your car is probably about
10 9 10. it's a 2006 lexus rx 330. i'm
gonna take a guess and say it's gonna be
12 to 14 feet okay but most for the most
part no one knows what their vehicle
length is yeah but if you have a pickup
truck if you like a quad cab they're
right at 19 to 20 feet so they come in
and they bump the machine their hitch
bumps the machine just stops
so
machine stop guy pulls out of the car
wash this other vehicle just comes up it
just runs right through it and this big
machine sitting there doing nothing and
what it is there's an overload that gets
tripped and you got to just turn it back
on and it's this big giant thing he just
had this idea that you could just kind
of ram it and he rammed it three times
and it did just an astronomical amount
of damage it did tons of damage to our
car wash but we've got 4k security
cameras on everything it really didn't
look like it did much to the guy's
issue but you know who's who pays for
that
his insurance because we got the license
plates
wow
[Music]
what if he's under insured i mean if you
say 600
a hundred thousand um we have really
good commercial insurance like okay our
our um
adjuster could not believe how
over-insured we were because we were
like someone's going to hit these
machines like it's guaranteed we're new
operators were bad things were going to
happen and took three months and then
someone ramped it so how much did you
buy this car wash for and how much is it
making per month
so this is public record we paid 675 000
for both locations plus the storage
locker facility i will get in trouble if
i tell you guys how much
it makes because
my business partner wants me to put it
behind a paywall you we could block it
out and then you just get out we'll just
get our reaction but also but also why
why behind a paywall what's this because
i want to do training for car washes and
profitable business designs like i
really need to explain to people i'll do
the reaction shot we're doing about a
month
off the car washes so yeah i mean but
here's the thing to me that seems
it's it's profitable but it's nothing
that i'd be like oh my god now here's my
thought is that it it you should tell
people how much it makes because that
would be
that would be
so much more enticing to people
than i know
believe me i know
and well you could show him this why do
you even need a partner on that
because i'm not mechanically inclined
enough to service car wash pockets
it's so expensive so i i also looked
into buying a car wash and i think it
was 125 and it was in downey california
and uh and it made a lot of money i
think it was like it was supposed to
make like 30 a year or it was like it
was some amount where i was like or no
it was like 50 000 a year for a 125 car
wash but the thing was that uh
maintenance was so high one thing and he
my business partner is so good with the
mechanical stuff he's found and he's got
a guy trained we got a part-time
maintenance tech and i haven't had to do
anything i've been collect money for
probably like well i had to show up
twice in the past five weeks but i went
three weeks to do anything
and
we're trying to do is come up with a car
wash system so we can just go and buy
all the car washes in our region
because he they're just big you get them
on a proper maintenance cycle when you
do the right things then they just print
they print money what other businesses
have you thought about getting into uh
what about gas stations um
i would like to buy one just to have one
guest
just to put that in the collection yeah
it would be fun i think it'd be fun um
but one of the things i talked to like
the atm kingpin of nevada before i came
here
i like it probably five hours ago
and he's we were talking numbers on
those and oh my gosh and he's doing
bitcoin atms and all this different
stuff we just talked about all these
crazy things what is he doing
oh he didn't tell me a number but it's
millions a month
um how do you well i just in fees
bitcoin atm at cannabis dispensaries
because it gets around the banking law
how smart is that
oh my gosh
yeah
it's a stuff i like you i don't know
think about that
that is absurd think about but he showed
me one and i'm like and it can read
checks it can take cash deposits give
out cash deposits it's like we got a
nice chase brands branch where i am in
ohio and it like spits everything out
you have to pay get money out of it from
an atm
check cashing all this different stuff
it's like that kiosk but it's
self-maintained i don't get why the
cannabis dispensaries don't just have
their own bitcoin atm if it's that
profitable
i think that it's a violation of banking
laws because whenever you i'm sure i
mean the the forms are federal does your
business involve the sale of
and you know gambling
and
marijuana and things like that there's
like a list do you do these things and
if you check that box then boom you're
not getting an account so that's why
most of these cannabis dispensaries are
transacting everything in cash and
they're paying
gobs of money to like i don't know that
they do lloyds of london i think they
just do loomis and brings like the cash
transport services those fees are in
some cases worse than um credit card
fees like the interchange fees and
everything they can be like two to three
percent
like just to handle the cash and
sometimes they're more like three
percent on cash stored
so what happens is if you can transact
on site and you're acting as kind of an
intermediary and you can kind of
transact with bitcoin or you can do
something that isn't actual physical
cash storage it's just there's so much
opportunity that's out there but it's
you know just it comes down to can you
figure it out can you structure it can
you find a way to scale it and if you
can get to the point that you can come
up with a
scale model then all of a sudden magical
things happen
and i i know people that have vending
machines i mean i think you did on the
graham stefan show you had jaime ibanez
yes we did back in 2019 and he came to
ohio and um behind me and liz and i we
talked back and forth and he's like
scaling and scaling and scaling his
vending business i think he's up to like
i could be wrong but just on his vending
site he's making like 300 000 a year
and it's his time commitment from my
understanding is can continuing to not
be terrible like 20 25 hours a week i
could be wrong there but it's not a lot
and it's because he's figured out the
scale and he's figured out the logistics
to make sure everything's efficient
inside that operation it's something
that's with vending machines we have
fittings the vending machines have been
around for almost 100 years
but he's efficient about it laundromats
have been around since the 30s and
there's people out there they're just
killing it because they're finding out
how to be efficient at scale and car
wash is the same thing mr carwash
recently had an ipo and their market cap
is higher than what the car wash
industry produced in 2019. like a 40
billion dollar
market cap and the car wash industry as
a whole did like 10.5 billion in 2019.
wow yeah so they're doing four acts of
what the entire car wash industry made
revenue-wise not net
these are incredible businesses
you don't even think about it that's
what i like about it is that these are
businesses that
you you walk by it all the time and and
no one ever tells you hey
uh maybe own an atm it's weird it's like
i never use atms
i never use laundromats i have maybe
once or twice i rarely ever use car
washes i
i believe me i i use my family to use
the laundromat once before i bought one
use a car wash like once or twice a year
get the salt off my car because i live
in ohio like maybe used car washes 20
times in my entire life then i bought
one
um i got into rentals and my family
pretty much grew up only in reynolds
that my parents didn't own a house until
like 2005. so i'm doing all these things
i have no no experience in which i would
think gives hope for people because you
can do things that you have no
experience and just you know got to
learn quick but you can do it so
can you say your total portfolio value
oh it's like in
gosh i need i keep doing revaluations
because my area of ohio keeps going up
higher and higher and higher but it's
about six oh
about 8 million at this point and how
much my debt service is probably 2.5 2.6
million it's like six million yeah five
five six million
there that's like your that's like your
net worth yeah there's there's some
caveats in there like i've got some
equity loans with people and they get
like 25 35 40 of whatever a individual
property sells for so then that's not
all my general debt services because
that's what i'm paying on just like my
loan balances but i've got a few of
those deals but they're not
that doesn't kick my net worth down
severely
but what's amazing to me is how much of
that was created based off of active
income versus like i mean one could
argue that like owning a laundromat and
you know buying rental properties and
stuff is somewhat active because you're
always working on it but versus like
like a salaried income or some sort of
income where like you had to work for it
like like when you're a real estate
agent or something like that what
percent of that growth was from
something like that versus just buying a
property and then you know it's cash
flows and oh it's more passive
investments it the the actual true
passive investment site it's all from
equity growth and it's like
you go out and you buy a car wash and
you spend 600 000 on it and then you go
and
if you buy it on a 10 cap rate and then
all of a sudden you're doing a 25 cap
rate
and the business truly was worth let's
say
we should use better numbers let's say
you buy a car wash it's a million and
you're at a 10 cap rate so it's clearing
net 100k a year and you double that
net at 200k a year you've gone from a
one million dollar car wash to 2 million
car wash
and that is not hard to do at all one of
our locations right now we're up 45
percent in terms of gross sales and then
we've pulled our expenses actually
dropped down because my business
partners why why i like him so much he
has gone through and he has chased down
every problem like water leaks found a
garden hose that was going full blast to
this storm server for no reason
whatsoever turned that off tracked it
down shouldn't have been on that saved
like five hundred dollars five hundred
dollars a month for a year six thousand
dollars you drop your cost basis down
six thousand dollars a year on you take
that off of your
um hundred thousand years now you're
making 106 000. it's amazing to me that
you've been able to build a 5.5 million
dollar like net worth basically all off
of like in the beginning like you had
investors and stuff yeah you started
investing in real estate and then slowly
just like growing your own portfolio all
the while it's like that is a that's
absurd to me congratulations kudos to
you like that's
amazing i mean i realistically i think
it would happen to anybody if you'd own
as many properties as i do and you
waited long enough because now i'm now
i'm in the process of selling down my
single family detached because they're
just so much equity in them so
we'll i'm in the process
we'll sell about a million dollars worth
and if my math right we should clear
like a net is 650 on it so 350 000 of
debt principal curtailment that with
i'll clear 650 on it
but my cash flow is not going to be hurt
really too much at all because our
our my apartment segments just getting
better and better and better we're going
and throwing ten thousand dollars into
unit we're seeing like a 20 to 30 20 to
40 percent increase in gross rents and
it's just it's incredible makes me want
to invest
me too
because seeing what we could have done
is just we could just give you money and
uh so yeah how much actually do a
syndication when i go home i know what
about self storage
storage facility do you own any of those
yeah i got a 38 unit 38 how has your
experience been with that it's good now
that i have an assistant it was it was
bad when we took it over because all the
people were elderly they were paying by
checks
no one was on the same date
and then i had my assistant say hey
guess what you now get all of the late
fees so i want to make sure that late
fees are applied to every account as per
the lease agreement that we took over
from the facility i wanna you know we
wanna make sure that each unit's rented
out an appropriate time frame we'll give
you the tools to advertise on facebook
we're gonna buy banners whatever it is
necessary for you to be able to
advertise them you're going to do it and
we're gonna pay your regular rate plus
bonuses based on perform not so much
performance but
figuring out how to fix the problems the
underlying problems within the self
storage facility so we took it over and
we're probably at 30 percent vacancy and
i think
i looked at the chart before i came on
monday and i think
like replicas like 95 percent
um but i'm probably going to take the
remaining five for my rental stuff
because we are our rates lower than the
median we probably should raise rates
but we just don't feel like it and it's
overall it's a well performer but what
we're wanting to do is come in with like
some security features and
whatnot the storage industry can be a
big money maker but i don't
see a lot of money being made for
taking over and doing value ads i mean
there's plenty of value ads that are out
there i don't see them all the big money
to be made from my perspective is a new
construction because there's still a
huge difference between an efficient
build versus what the markets can bear
in a well-built well-built out location
there's a shortfall of
storage units what's your advice to
somebody watching who's going to hear
your story they're going to be
i want to do that
what's what's the first step what
business do they go into
how do they learn about this
what should they avoid
how do they start out let's say they
have
a few grand saved up
my big thing is like if i get this
question i'm sure you could do too it's
like what would you do if you're me and
it'll be
i'm gonna tell you the most boring thing
ever i'm gonna go tell you to put all
your money in vti or vo
and then spend the next six months and
figure out look at vending machines or
car washes or whatever find something
you think you can be really passionate
about do all your research
do all the legwork to see if there's an
opportunity out there there might not be
an opportunity out there there's plenty
of locations where vending can't be done
or atms can't be done you can't do a car
wash you can't do a laundry right you
can't there's just no opportunity out
there
go you know
at least you've made some money on that
money and you you're not pressed for
time because people were like i got two
thousand dollars burning hole in my
pocket i'm gonna buy a vending machine
i'm like you don't know a single thing
about it and you don't know anything
about location you might not be good at
prospecting or talking to business
owners i mean that might you just might
suck at it there's people there's a
certain personality that you need for
atms of vending you might not have it so
it'd be really stupid for me to tell
somebody just go out you know this is
this is what you have to do but i think
if you take that pressure off and you
can see a little bit of money growing
even if it's just like a couple thousand
dollars sitting in vo of eti they did
pretty good the best two years
um then that way that pressure's off and
you can go out and you can find
something to get into i know people in
southern ohio they flip cars
i could not flip a car to save my life
if my life depended on i would die if i
had to flip cars but i know guys and
that they make
a killing off just buying cheap cars and
reselling them there's certain cars they
like and they just have two or three
thousand dollars just constantly cycle
the money over
i don't have the personality for that
but they sure sure as heck do i know
guys that they flip mowers they go and
they get riding lawn mowers and push
mowers and they just have they have a
little nest egg of cash and they flip
small engines constantly they just love
it and they make money at it and there's
so many other things that i've seen out
there like small engine repair flipping
you can make 100 150 bucks an hour doing
it but i it's hard for me to say this
certain personality subsets exactly that
you have to do this or you have to do
these things just go out and explore the
things see what your personality meshes
with practically everything you can
learn on youtube right now the knowledge
of the world's on there and then just
find something that your personality
meshes with but then don't be so afraid
that you're going to fail because i mean
i've got all sorts of businesses i
failed in my when i was 15 years old i
ran on online paintball store
and absolutely
crash into the ground because i didn't
know anything about accounting
i knew now what i knew about counting
i'd probably been a multi-millionaire
because we were selling stuff on ebay
back in 2001.
wow yeah back in the wild west yeah it's
crazy okay i have a question for you
yeah yeah okay yes i have ten thousand
dollars in my robin oh eleven thousand
dollars in my robin hood now okay uh
it's money congratulations thanks it's
money i don't really need
uh investment like i have retirement
accounts obviously i need the money i'm
not like this is play money which is
good no it's not playing money because
i'm not like
super
wealthy
um but honestly i'm thinking of pulling
all my money out of robin hood and using
it to to
generate more money because i i need to
bring in more more money like totally
passive or are you wanting a moonshot
that's the problem i mean um i would
have to be something i can do on the
weekends okay so you want a little
business you can do on the weekends yeah
because i used uh when i first started
making money i used about ten thousand
dollars to launch my wedding business
okay i moved out here i closed my
wedding business um but i also can't
spend 80 hours a week on this business
what do you recommend yeah what do you
recommend go rent some tick tock people
that don't understand business
go buy their channel
license their content buy their channel
and then repurpose it set up a business
plan for them to monetize their content
they're currently not monetizing
i don't get it could you i think that's
yeah can you please explain money
i don't care
okay i'm not going to say this person's
name i know a guy on tick tock he's got
750 000 followers he posts any video he
gets half a million views
last time i had the conversation he's
been on tick tock for two years he's
made six thousand dollars
that level of influence is worth a lot
more than six thousand dollars i think
anybody in alex's situation where he's
got a phenomenal eye towards art
artistry
he's got a good understanding of the
back end of the business i would go and
take ten thousand dollars and i would go
find let's say two people on tick tock
that aren't making any money just go
send out dms to a lot of people and say
are you making the money that you want
to on tick tock i want to license you i
want to pay for
low balance fifty dollars of video for
the next i want i want to own the next
100 pieces of your content find people
that are good at their content and you
you unders you can feel this you
understand um
what's good
say i want to prepay or i want to buy
the next hundred tick tock posts and
then you've helped them segment their
content to something that can make money
and i i don't know what that is um i was
talking to somebody just trying to get
them set up with an amazon affiliate
store because they were they were
talking about things that were highly
sellable not big money but you know
amazon affiliates who make six percent
and just doing the math they should be
making probably
2500 bucks a month off their channel
and they just could not do it they
didn't have the ability to set up the
amazon affiliate store
nothing
so i would take your skill set i would
take ten that ten thousand dollars if
it's just money and then i would go in
and i would start you know let's call it
a mini influencer agency and then i
would just print tick tockers out set up
some offers and um go
and
you'll make all the money back but then
you'll help people grow the brand and
then they can maybe slowly step out of
um
it's amazing how many people i run into
on tick tock and even instagram to a
point they just don't have the business
understanding but they've got the
audience and you can rent audiences
so
i had that same idea
did you yeah a few months ago there's a
lot of people that idea but no one it's
like everything else yeah ideas are uh
yeah and it's the implementation as time
goes on i just get aggravated because i
got all these crazy ideas seen people do
that with only fans is that they've
they've gone to some creators and
basically said well if we split the
income that it makes i'll make sure you
make five times more and you could use
the houses the cars these connections uh
uh we'll use this promotion but we just
split a fifty-fifth yeah and there's a
lot of people that are famous out there
that aren't making the money i i don't
want to i don't want to third names
around but
tick tock very recently lost their top
influencers to hulu
and the problem is it's like tick-tock
if the only reason they left is because
they weren't making enough money and
i've talked to quite a few people and
they either handle the influence and the
traffic very very well or they just
don't what's hulu doing
they probably pay them between 50 and
100 million dollars for a show so oh
you're doing a hulu show
so now their top tier content is going
to be on i'll do a show
give me a show hulu yeah
so i'll leave tick tock
so it's just it's just an influence
influence deal and how you're using
your marketing and your brand because
every you know everybody if you'd really
think about most people have a personal
brand at least as far as your
professional network goes you know
people you have at least a little bit of
influence on people and you can utilize
those connections you know when you were
doing real estate you had influence you
know you real estate full-time you're
using your influence and your personal
brand to convince people to buy a house
through you
um and people have that in their own
life but they don't understand a lot of
times how to make any money off of it my
mom cleaned people's houses when we were
from the time i was probably 16 to the
time i was 21 my mom cleaned houses and
she just could not
ever accept the fact that she was worth
three to four times more than she was
charging people
and i look back and like well i really
wish you would have charged more for
what you were worth you had the appeal
you had the brand you had the following
why didn't you act why didn't you do it
and they're always well i just didn't
think i needed to i'm like mom you're
cleaning houses for rich people and we
were dirt poor we could i mean we had
holes in our wall growing up there was
there were
i don't know that was specifically the
time saying my mom was cleaning the
house because i think we eventually
fixed it with duct tape but we had holes
in the wall and my brother and i sleep
on diesel furnace exhausts
like you know mom it would have been
pretty cool if you would have charged
more to clean people's houses would have
been nice
and you know as much as i love my
parents i'm like you know she didn't
understand that she had that influence
in that appeal that she had that she had
a product that was great
but she didn't understand the worth of
her own value and a lot of people run
into that
that problem if we'd be honest about it
they've got they've got the product and
brand appeal but they have very strong
difficulties monetizing it and it's like
i wish that i had the logistical ability
and the time to go through and just make
those connections
and um
there's a lot of people sit in the
background that are doing very well off
youtube they don't have a channel they
don't do anything they just connect
people i've known some guys and they're
beasts
right now setting up
like creator houses they're going and
doing real estate deals and providing
housing for youtubers and people on tick
tock so they have a place to create
content with no overhead and then
they're kind of taking percentages of
people's channels
based on the fact that they're providing
the housing and the equipment and i mean
just i was talking to somebody about
that two weeks ago three weeks ago maybe
like man that's an insane play and their
statement to me was you know you have
all these rentals in southern ohio like
we should start sending people to you
and then that'll fix all your editing
problems and all your content creation
problems like wow gosh you know yeah
just go and do it for me because i have
i don't have the time but it's just
there's just
the bigger to me it's like the bigger
you grow
in social media influence and all that
different stuff what happens is you just
realize the fields are wider and bigger
and more robust there's just more stuff
to do i'd hate i imagine if you were
someone like elon musk he probably has
20 times more ideas that are on the
shelf beyond
you know tesla spacex the boring company
and uh whatever else he's in
you know i'd hate to be in his shoes
with that might with that
mental capacity and that ability i'm
sure there's all these things he's not
able to exercise and not and even worse
not be able to find the right people to
mesh with them yeah you know what's
really funny uh when you were talking
about promoting on reddit
i i remember there was a guy
promoting on reddit and i was really
jealous of him because he had 200
subscribers
and i had maybe 50.
and you were doing i'm guessing it was
you
was it you
because i did comment on that channel
and it like crazy yeah
it got banned
yeah because i was like this is
self-promotion and uh like i got my post
removed right where i did something
similar to you yeah and they removed
mine but yours was up there but yours
was up there because i i'm guessing it
was you because you wrote a whole novel
in it yes that was you yeah and you went
in through these houses
that's crazy so this is when i was like
20 subscribers 30 students it was
forever
very very beginning i'm not sure what
happened because you could go on youtube
and you can sort your comments by
subscriber count so it would show the
top creators first on your youtube
account and at some point number one was
graham and i was like oh my gosh that's
cool and i sent you a screenshot on
discord and at some point it disappeared
because i tried going in like a month or
two ago when we started talking about
getting this set up and i was like oh
i'm going to find this screenshot so i
can make sure that
i've got a document because i thought
i'd be fun for the this podcast yeah
this was it
oh yeah there we go
february 16th 2017
yes you were the one who i saw on reddit
i've never put the two and two together
until just now and it's funny you
mentioned that because i was thinking
who is that guy and i was like i wonder
where he is now yeah do you have any
advice for us what could we be doing
better
i don't want to tell you to make shorts
because then you'll start beating me out
so she got the shorts
oh i mean i i think people have been
telling us yeah we shouldn't i think i
think shorts will do very well i think
they're there's i think there's still a
lot of room for them to grow they'll
peak and they'll decline kind of like
vines did but i think there's
the ability to get a lot of traffic off
of them um
then the other thing is i would start
look work on more digital products hire
a guy to run a sales funnel for you
and then just start doing a sales cycle
on digital products because you got
enough of a following but then you've
got to kind of decide whether you want
to sell trade some of your influence
equity
to people but you could make a crap a
lot of money off that
that's i like the shorts idea i'm good
at the show the second one's kind of i
don't think that graham would want to do
it you would do want to do it though
i think you want to make money well
depends yeah it is yeah anyway
thank you so much thanks for coming i
really appreciate this man this went so
well you are one of the smartest guests
i think we've had on genuinely genuinely
i took an iq test before i came and came
back negative so i was really starting
to call and question my sanity that's
impressive that's actually so impressive
i would consider that genius
so
thank you man
now do you want to tell them to
subscribe
subscribe button yeah please smash the
like button and subscribe to the iced
coffee hour
because jack jack needs jack needs some
money jack needs money today we hit 200
000 subscribers thank you guys so much
that is
absolutely amazing thank you we really
appreciate it thanks for coming on
brandon oh nice to meet you in person
after talking about mine
discord for freaking two years and uh
with that said you guys have a great
free stock down below in the description
center mentorship group link down below
probably yeah you should sign up to the
mentorship program and talk and to them
and gain valuable insight